okay so Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness takes us on a two-hour trip
through alternate universes in the
pursuit of getting America Chavez the
[ __ ] away from Wonder hide your wife
hide your kids because someone is gonna
have to raise them and I have to say
that I absolutely love the film I know
it's very divisive with people saying
the plot is messy and that there's some
disappointing aspects in terms of things
like the Illuminati but I had a complete
blast so I thought I'd revisit the film
and discuss some of the big questions
people have about the character turns
the plot holes and just general issues
that I see popping up this video is
gonna include things like why wonders
kids are the same even though vision
isn't there where the deadbeat bot is
why read is the dumbest smartest man on
earth why Gamora didn't cause an
incursion and basically as many
questions as I can fit into one video
before Wanda shows up to take my twins
away yay now it's full spoilers ahead
sub you haven't seen the movie and that
intro didn't ruin it for you then please
hit the green light and stop the video
if you enjoy our breakdown we love you
in every Universe if you decide to like
And subscribe and without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
Doctor Strange too okay so the first big
thing I want to discuss is why Wanda's
kids are the same in the 8-8 universe
wengie created them using magic in one
division surely they wouldn't be exactly
the same because the ones in the
alternate reality were conceived the
old-fashioned way whereas the ones in
the hex just shut up out of nowhere like
those that post full cam spoiler clips
on YouTube two days before the film
releases I know who you are now it is
pretty confusing unless we take it that
the Westview ones weren't who came first
Billy and Tommy are roughly about 10
years old I think and therefore they
would have had to have been alive for
that length of time if they're real one
division only happened recently in terms
of the MCU timeline and therefore they
would have been created after the real
ones in the alternate universe if we
look at the a38 in general they're far
more advanced than the 616 timeline and
that's because the snap never happened
and therefore they had five years of
developing things the this is why we see
a Reed Richards who's at the height of
his powers when we haven't even had him
show up in the 616 yet they might even
be more than five years ahead but either
way you slice it up there's definitely a
major time difference in terms of how
advanced they are now how Wanda managed
to make two kids that are exactly the
same is explaining the movie through
them discussing dreams we learned that
when one dreams that the person doing so
is actually seeing their alternate self
in another reality therefore in 616
Wanda would have likely dreamed about
her ultimate itself met her kids that
way and then subconsciously brought them
to life we learned that in every other
reality that Wanderers with their kids
whereas in the 616 she isn't so
therefore she would have definitely
encountered them at several points and
that kind of segues me into the next
point which is who is the daddy whilst
it would be easy to say Vision
unfortunately a Dunning that he exists
in the a38 universe and even if he does
the events of One Division definitely
didn't happen now we never meet Tony
Stark in this reality and therefore it's
unlikely that he actually exist there
however we do meet Ultron Bots which is
why everyone on the internet thought
that Tom Cruise could show up as
Superior Iron Man however I don't think
that these were created by the character
and instead I believe that Reed Richards
was the person behind them dubbed the
smartest man on earth if he really is
that then he probably created them
without the flaws and the main Ultron
wooden carry aspects of the personality
that Tony has so Reed likely figured it
all out and because Ultron Works he
never tried to make Vision like what we
saw in Age of Ultron however even if the
events of Age of Ultron did somewhat
happen and we got a version of vision
his time with Wonder would have been a
lot different in the movie we learned
that the Illuminati killed Thanos on
Titan and with this happening it means
that he never would have gone to Earth
and ripped the Mind Stone out of
vision's head because this didn't happen
Wanda would have never grieved him
created the hex and then become the
Scarlet Witch so Ultron working his
intended changes the course of the MCU
and instead I think that billion Tommy's
dad are probably just some random guy
which is a nice message I suppose now
we're going even further into a segue
from this to talk about why the
Illuminati don't care about wonder even
though strange tries to desperately warn
them that she's coming to Matrix their
mouths that's because as they say in
their reality strange is the biggest
threat after dreamwalking too much
Supreme strange cause an incursion that
killed trillions of people because it
wiped out an entire reality thus Wonder
Isn't as big of a threat even though we
as the viewers know how dangerous she is
this also kind of ties into why they
don't really care and at one point
Captain Marvel even says that they can
handle strangest little witch now
because all of the prior events like Age
of Ultron Civil War Infinity war end
game and one division never happened
their wonder is pretty deep powered he'd
probably be about Age of Ultron level
which is why they think they're fine
just sending lots of Ultron Bots after
her as she was pretty scared of them in
that film in the comics the arrogance
and hubris of the Illuminati always
letter their downfall and they just
don't see wander as a threat to them
because they're used to dealing with
there one day they've probably also
looked into other realities and have
seen that in 99.9 of them that she's
just a full-time Yummy Mummy who spends
most of her days making her kids ice
creams so just like meh we can handle
her this arrogance an underestimation of
her is why they weighed into the battle
completely unprepared and why Reed even
tells her about black Bolt's power
because they're pretty idiotic a lot of
fans have said that it's a wasted
opportunity to introduce them like this
and I do kind of agree with them on some
level however the whole point of them is
to make us think that Wanda has finally
met her match but she completely
overpowers them they are supposed to
represent the best team on one of the
best Earths and the fact that Wanda
turns them into pasta just elevates the
threat now I know a lot of chatter
online is about how we've waited years
for Professor Rex and also John
Krasinski to show up as Mr Fantastic to
throw them away seems pretty stupid but
I believe in my heart of hearts that all
these characters will be back in some
form or another Disney of course
acquired 20 Century Fox so they'll
likely be doing an X-Men movie soon we
know that a Fantastic Four is right
around the corner Captain Carter is
confirmed to show up in season two of
what if Maria will probably be back in
some form or another in the Marvels and
Black Bolt yeah sure get him back in
another Earth so the majority of these
characters will return in upcoming
projects either centered around them or
with them in the background for like two
seconds now was The Illuminati's
inclusion disappointing hmm it kind of
depends if you're more bothered about
the cameos than what they're supposed to
represent but let me know below exactly
what you think now with them comes a lot
of exposition about incursions which
massively pulls from the comics in the
source material what happens is that Two
Worlds start to move towards each other
on a collision course that will destroy
both of them those on the other worlds
have to either accept their fate or
Fighter the death until they destroy the
other reality which massively ties in
the secret Wars event this will likely
be the Big Arc that's coming around the
corner and we discover that if one
enters Another Universe through
dreamwalking then it will start to
create a footprint there this will
eventually cause an incursion and that
will destroy the reality now this is
very much why strange and Christine
can't be together even though the pair
both have feelings for one another if
they were to live in a reality together
it would eventually pull either the 616
or 838 towards it which would lead to a
path of Destruction so they say goodbye
at the end with strange saying he loves
her in every Universe I'm not I'm not
crying you're crying now the reason that
America Chavez and Claire can do this is
because neither used the dark hole to
dreamwalk as we see Claire Cuts up and
reality into the dark dimension so she
can enter and exit whatever Universe She
Wants to this way we also discover that
America is the only version of herself
that exists in the entire Multiverse
urges being here means there's no one
for her to pop it in another reality and
therefore no incursions will be caused
there's actually another similarity with
the dark hold the book of Ashanti and
America that we learn about in the film
we discover that the dark old was
created for the Scarlet image and even
see statues of Tommy and belly at The
Fortress later on Gotham created this in
every Universe to bring about the
prophesized Scarlet Witch and that is
why there's a Wonder in dark hold in
every reality however there's only one
book of Ashanti because there's only one
America both very much represent their
own books and when we see the pages of
the shantiopian there's even a star
there like what America has now the
reason Gamora doesn't cause an incursion
endgame is because technically she's
from the same reality as the one that
died the events of Loki hadn't really
transpired at that point and therefore
every time there was a branch timeline
created the TVA shut it down they also
said in Loki that end game was meant to
happen the way it did so they wouldn't
ever wipe out Gamora she comes from 2014
in that reality and therefore when her
past self-travels to the Future it
doesn't create an incursion because he's
still from the 616. this is the same
with Steve Rogers he used the quantum
tunnel to travel back through time in
the 616 reality and it was from here
that he created a branch timeline with
Peggy Carter the way light is used in
the film also reflects are the worlds
which is why America's has different
colors in it because it's on a different
color spectrum whereas the 616 looks the
same throughout now a major criticism
I've seen about the film is that it
undoes wonders Arc in one division
personally I don't really see that as
being true and in the post-credits scene
we left it on our own studying the dark
hole looking for her kids we pick up
with her studying the dark hole looking
for her kids and though it's getting
compared to Daenerys from Game of
Thrones I think there's actually way
more setup here wonder is also corrupted
by the dark hole which is why she's not
really that reasonable anymore and if
you can accept that Sinister strange was
turned evil by it then you can accept
that Wonder was too I'm telling you
you'll accept it remember this is a book
that prophesies the rise of the Scarlet
Witch and thus it was written purely
with the intent of corrupting her in
order to turn her into someone that
would really entire Multiverse so there
is President there even if they do Rush
some of their character development now
her dying at the end could also explain
how I get in the Disney plus series I
get the house of Harkness at the end of
one division one attract Agatha in an
illusion but with her apparent death at
the film's clothes we could see Agatha
breaking out of this which would lead
into his solo series the film very much
brings a close to Wonder's Ark but we
could definitely see her back at some
point now it also does this with strange
he very much grows as a character
throughout the film early on Christine
says that he always has to be the one
holding the knife which is echoed by her
a3a counterpot however come the end of
the film he finally decides to hand
things over to America rather than
taking her power he no longer has to be
the one holding the knife and instead
can now trust others him fixing the
watch in the final few scenes also
represents a lot of things for the
character the first film ended with
strange staring at the watch in the
sanctorum accepting that he was broken
but still powering through it however
this film ends with him repairing it
showing how he's very much overcame the
internal issues he had over losing
Christine were also introduced to clear
in the post credit scene who actually
ends up becoming his wife in the comics
I guess as one portal closes another one
opens and it's a great way to take the
character now lastly does want to get
back on The Lunchbox nope and that's the
video we didn't cover the post credit
scene in this one as we already have a
big breakdown on it and that will be
linked on screen right now if you want
to go and check it out we've also
covered the Illuminati a bit more in
depth so head over there right after
this if you want to learn about their
past and powers in the comics without
the way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been poor let's see in the
next one take care peace